j'aime manière payante obtenu le match
nul 0 0 hier soir chez eux face à brest
mais les supporteurs ont pour leur part
assisté à une première
larbitre de terrain était une femme
stéphanie fera par premier arbitre
central dans le foot professionnel
masculin après corinne diacre qui
entraîne le clermont foot certains
bastions masculins commencent à tomber
marine rando nier et sandrine leclerc
c'est une image que les femmes du foot
auront longtemps attendu voici stéphanie
fera par 31 ans entouré des arbitres de
touche en reconnaissance sur le terrain
juste avant le match de ligue 2 new york
brest hier soir sur la toute nouvelle
pelouse du stade rené gaillard c'est
elle la patronne
ses vents d'arbitrage sous les crampons
dont trois en national stéphanie et la
tête sur les épaules et des capacités
physiques impressionnantes à la mi temps
toujours pas de but mais les supporters
valine l'arbitrage ainsi qu il faut
siffler
qu'ils foutent c'est bien et est très
posé présent toujours présente de
réaction donc automatiquement l a
toujours fait ce qu'il fallait et il a
pu prendre des décisions qu'il fallait
au bon moment le plus frappant c'est le
respect des joueurs face à l' arbitre la
jeune femme parvient à asseoir son
autorité
alors bien sûr il conteste mais beaucoup
moins qu'avec un homme
[Applaudissements]
quand on prend les bonnes décisions tu
vois bien après tout joueur reste un
compétiteur donc si elle la contestation
sur le terrain voilà on essaye de gérer
il n'y a pas de différence entre un
homme et une femme j'espère que ça va
susciter des vocations
donc j'invite toutes les femmes à
prendre le sifflet est allé sur les
rencontres et essayer de promouvoir
l'art d'être chez moi je trouve
globalement l a fait avec elle a fait
son match et eu très peu de tension sur
la fin parce qu'on sentait bien que les
deux équipes jouent leur leur bateau et
puis qu'il y avait des choses qui se
jouer à peu de chose mais il faut la
féliciter de son son premier match en
professionnel c'est pas toujours évident
les conditions de jeu n'étaient pas
faciles aussi donc un an bravo un brain
quelques erreurs d'hier ont quand même
les côtés des joueurs le travail d'armes
est très difficile mais ça c'est pareil
pour les hommes et pour les femmes
[Musique]